to astrobiology and why it is important
and then i'll be talking about my
personal experiences as well
so why is it important to everyone let's
start from that one of the most
important factors is that it helps us
understand evolution better and
currently we are looking as registered
for biosignatures in outer space and
these include fossils or any other
chemicals that are residues of living
organisms
if we do find signs of life or water
in space this will help us gauge how
earth is going to evolve going into the
future and we can better adapt to it
another reason space studies are
crucial is because a lot of equipment we
use
on a daily basis is an extension of the
equipment that was invented for space
missions
some examples include artificial limbs
insulin pumps cat scans baby formula and
fire fighting equipment but of course
it's not limited to these um the
challenging conditions presented for
space missions has forced us to be more
creative and gave a boost to our daily
lives as well
and last but not least what we should be
excited about astrobiology because the
space travel age is observing novel
improvements and space tourism might be
available to the general public
therefore it is a field that concerns
all of us
so a little bit about my personal
experience uh it's it actually started
ideologically i just do not think that
we could be alone in this universe and
there has to be other life forms in
space that are either similar to or very
different from organisms on earth
and
also i have another connection to space
is and that is the salda lake that in
turkey and i'm turkish as well
um and recently the structure of zelda
lake was compared to formations on the
surface of mars the microorganisms also
the lake use sediments and minerals in
the water to form rocks and if
similar rocks are found on mars that is
an indication that there was once water
on the surface of mars as well
i this is very exciting to me i don't
know if it's because i'm a biologist but
um this is quite literally a new age and
uh i couldn't be happier to be
living during this time to be honest
i'm also very excited about the way
inventions for space translate to our
daily lives
it can help us find new treatments and
drugs for certain diseases that we
cannot um push through and find a new
drug for on earth itself
and of course there's also the fact that
it is a challenging field and i love a
good challenge
and
what is important to look for and is
very challenging for space studies is
habitability
we have to understand what makes our
bodies and earth habitable and we can uh
use that to make other planets habitable
too so understanding space will help us
discover habitability factors
if we do find life forms in space like
microorganisms we can study the
disappearance of factors that cause
these microorganisms to go extinct and
hence shape the evolution of these
microbes on earth to prevent it from
happening here so far since 2015
astronaut left microbes in space in a
box that is exposed to radiation and
other
extreme conditions
and they have adapted and continued to
survive so this is um actually great
news which means
even if we cannot find life in space in
the near future
and i believe that eventually we will
we know that at least we can adapt some
species to space and
they can use resources on mars to
provide oxygen and nutrition for us and
there are actually studies going on in
berman university in germany
to study how we can adapt microbes for
outer space to give us nutrition
and why i find micro especially um
very important and
i'm very excited about them it's because
they are everywhere and they are
symbionts so we cannot live without them
and there are 55 different microbes
found on the space station
and they are
expected because we cannot live without
microbes obviously but the european
space agency has also found that these
microbes that were within the
international space station have not
evolved to be more harmful to humans or
more resistant to antibiotics however
the effect of different conditions in
space like extreme exposure to radiation
and change in diets
can cause disorders in humans and this
was what my project was based on
these disorders can be direct or
indirect like the gut microbiome
expecting neural health or
the uh the microbiome of the space
station affecting the skin health of
astronauts
so i will be
delving more into gut